- Are you like this-
because I hate acting,
but I love-
I feel like I do it on stage
cause you jump into character
of wherever you were
when you wrote the song.
- [Ann] Right. Yeah, yeah.
- Is that ever hard for you?
Depending upon this song?
Like, you know, like-
- For me it's not the
songs that are too intense,
It's the ones that I've grown out of.
- [Kelly] Ah.
- Like, you know,
I don't wanna say anything
about too specific songs, but-
- You don't want to like poo
poo on the songs, but yeah.
- But a song like "Magic Man", you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Was written way back when I
was in my super early twenties
and with my first love and-
- Don't you bash "Magic
Man" right now, ma'am.
- (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- I will-
- That's what I meant,
yeah.
- I will actually tackle you.
- That's what I meant. I don't
wanna bash any song, but-
- You know why?
I think it was actually the
first Heart song I ever heard,
as a child.
And I was like-
and it, honestly it was
because it was women.
- Yeah.
- And usually you always heard
men doing the rock stuff.
And so, I remember- cause my
brother's like a decade older,
anything they were listening
to was always like men-
And I was like, wait, what? I can do this?
And it was like representation
at its finest point.
I was like, wait.
- [Ann] Right.
- Women are able to do this
too? And it was really cool.
Cause I feel like y'all
opened the door for all the-
for the Alanis Morissettes-
for all these women in music later on.
(audience applauds)
So next year is the 50th
anniversary of Heart.
- [Ann] Yeah.
- So that's amazing.
(audience applauds)
So, do you have any plans to celebrate?
I mean that's awesome. 50 years?
- We do.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But,
I gotta say it's too early days
for me to talk about it now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm not at liberty to discuss it.
- Oh, I like it.
- But- (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, that makes it a tease.
- But yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah. We are gonna do a thing.
- [Kelly] Okay, just asking for a friend.